why feeling that bonding the bonding
that happened when you're when you're
training like that under that kind of
stress I would assume I have no idea
because I've never been in military but
I would have so [ __ ] it a lot of kids I
would assume that he I resume with
fighting it's similar what soldiers go
through and go through something that
stressful and not too many people have
gone through it I don't know what else
to equate it to so they say maybe maybe
football like but even that that's not
like Bobby Lashley was on our team he's
small they say that one of the things
they talk about is when you that
insulting you compare fighting the
really not because what they think
they've done these studies that are
interesting when you have to fight when
you have to gonna comment on their
high-stress situations and your you
train under those your body actually
produces oxytocin which is a bonding
camp where you connect oh yeah it's even
the same guys I file like we'll get it
done
win or lose like even Travis Browne
right we had all that horrible beef
before even after I went to go like talk
with him because he like dude in this
can you what the [ __ ] dude yeah even
though I get my ass whooped and you know
he's dating my ex-girlfriend and his
team hates me yeah I still feel like all
even what we went through trumps that
that's right so I went over the talk and
even ki who hates me was like what son
man yeah good good fun let me say I'm
glad you're okay yeah he was cool you
say I'm glad you're alright
even that trumps all DUP all that
negativity sure he is coach well cuz
you're loath and I'm his coach who hated
me was like good job man it's good job
yeah you know like you're both you're
both an insane situation yes very
strange and you and it's a bonding thing
because you've both been through
something that very few people have been
there's a lot of like demons that creep
in a lot of self-doubt that you have to
fight no it's everything everything
that's why they're right every DC TJ's
apology I didn't well he hasn't polished
it almost starts crying yeah I think why
I why I almost like I get it like it's
not that I defend TJ I defend John when
they tested hot I I think why I can
relate to her why I'm just like God take
it easy guys it's because if anyone had
and not that guys aren't doing in some
Sanada
everyone is doing peds but I think I can
see why they do it that make sense okay
now or so then but even more so than you
like I've been through and I can see
especially at his level I'm like I I
think I have more compassion I get it
man
well I also look at this your greatest
strength which is your your deep drive
to win your competitiveness that drives
you to become the best you can be skill
wise can also have a dark side which is
you you you you know you'll do you'll
take a shortcut sometime Hooters with my
family this weekend you did there's the
only thing open there are no men where
there are no men who are waiting tables
there cuz that is outrageous
tell you what though this Hooters in
Long Beach all diving diamonds are worth
that right oh my god
yeah okay get your tits out of my face
room that's kind of where toon is your
creepy I drop them off you got family
there in your eyes or a Roman they want
a Rome but you don't let your eyes roam
you're just like oh what's is that the
bathroom right over there there it is
yeah they get some although you know
hooters now they can't hire based off
tits eyes anymore even though it's
called hooters I know do you know what
they have to do instead yes
no they get girls to wear three bras
three brawls
yeah push-ups so you wear like a nice
hire based off yeah so yeah you gotta
still wear multiple bras to make your
tits look huge there's some gorgeous
ones in Long Beach though yeah I
appreciate it make nice food too tits
and chicken wings hooters what a great
idea is there there's not a plate like
there's not like schlongs and just serve
hot dogs just guys in slice guys like
the game in those underwear and they're
just dick pieces out just plot slide
schlong snows like you know who would go
there yeah it's like it's like that's
how it works man no no [ __ ] girls
Mike should we go to Shuang do you like
it's not did I ever tell you how to
thunder down under' it's all giggle
balls I don't be a big balls
you have big balls the other kind of
balls yeah I got a big set of balls yeah
my big balls yeah I bet I had a ha my
balls hung low when I was in my 20s I
did a nude scene in acting class and a
girl goes your balls are
I was like hey man don't say that that
embarrasses you you like everywhere
short sleeves huh
is it the Kermit arms yeah got the
cook-off gods to the Kermit's a little
bit dude rock the Kermit's and my rocks
of pumpkin Jax think you with your arms
rock the pumpkin jack all right I will
no I I work short sleeve shirt just
can't really thing we have I just been
it's been a little chilly
okay I should wear my t-shirts has been
a tad blown my arms out bro well I was I
don't eat so when you lift weights you
don't need to stay skinny you know no
matter what you do what'd he say are you
too old
wait I mean I'm saying it's like you're
you get to eat all the food in the world
you know I can get fat you be nothing
you know like exactly the same thing
every time
at your age that's not sure I believe I
have the potential of único muscular man
I would TLT I feel in my heart that I
can still be a mesomorph do it man I
want to be the white Cheick Kongo oh you
could do that yeah I think if I really
really apply my little chick my cartoon
be red and Stimpy you'd be the little
chihuahua and I'd be the big whatever I
think he's a cat right one but why do
you get to be a cat and I have to be a
[ __ ]
xi1 rather be a dog than any cat yeah
see I'm the fat one on the on the yeah
I'm the one on the right I'm pretty sure
he's a cat and the guy in the laughs a
dog yeah once you know your way to
Walters but Ren and Stimpy that calm
once I seem watched it they took it off
air that [ __ ] was funny like my saying
why my son gonna watch it now it's way
too too racy
oh my god yeah Ren Stimpy was intense
dude hmm emotionally unstable Chihuahua
and Stimpy a good-natured yet dim-witted
cat Ren Stimpy dude there's that like
Buist Butthead beats about that the
movie was on the other day my son was
like oh it's this much a little bit like
ah man die see when I watched beavis and
butt-head they had a dog Oh
don't do that again and if you do it
again I'm gonna I'm gonna put myself I'm
gonna come at you oh yeah whatever but
that's hello Beavis and Butthead I was
watching it yeah they had a dog on a
leash
okay and it was in the road and a car
came along ran it over and ran it over
and it was a spot on the road and I went
home I went oh I don't know I I have to
watch this now and that's what got me
hooked on Beavis and buds on ran over a
dog
yes stories are annoying me today well
your [ __ ] sneezing is annoying me
dude I sneeze bro no you don't do that
welcome to the Jess story no when I
sneeze I say welcome Jon Snow here yeah
what are you ready when I was when I
walked the [ __ ] red carpet and I was
like this was when black man came out I
was on a TV show when I went to because
my buddy would directed a black night
with Martin Lawrence Marlon was the
height of his power Hall yeah movie bro
when he braum but when he came when he
came on the red carpet ha ha ha in the
way husband seat height I'm not
exaggerating I swear to God Russia they
were like listening that the paparazzi
you know those guys who take the
pictures they go get the [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out away get the [ __ ] out of the
way I got I mean it starts gonna die I
got so she'll suck I went they go get
away get out away and I go I don't want
be here and I want to see the movie I
got so mad that I I stormed off and I
socialize the [ __ ] night I damn
embarrassing there's a pecking order
David bear is it getting a [ __ ] they
didn't know who I was get out [ __ ] you
scream get the [ __ ] out of the way it
happened to me at the Golden Globes when
they're like we do you want to watch the
red carpet I'm like I guess anything's
always awkward also Lady gaga
Bradley Cooper like everyone's here I
just feel like it should be on like well
there's been some requests made to some
it's a giant saw am i okay so I'm in a
dominant crust
velvet and remember tuxedo
and I'm walk-in and then your do you you
wanna do the fashion cam like I've
always wanted to it yeah it'd be great
and then I'm like doing it and they're
like set everything up and then someone
yells out Lady gaga and then literally
it was like I was a [ __ ] mushroom on
the floor of course you're they stopped
all the cameras like let's just yeah you
get it
laters four by the way season we get it
later yeah maybe just go the side of the
okay I have to stand like a [ __ ]
bouncer while she [ __ ] this elegant
gown seventy people and just shut the
thing down shut it down get the [ __ ]
they date and how about how about 41 do
you have someone who goes Bryan Callen
and there's a piece of paper I don't do
it
Bryan Callen and there was a click and
there was my little Brendon Schwab I'm
like new a nutjob she goes
Schwab and then I go oh it's Tori no I
hacked you I like you so much noise I
hate to do this it's actually it's shop
shoes Schwab I'm like story of my
Hollywood life sir and when I did fat
actors it was a big show I'm chewing gum
oh wow that's a much like a ninja and my
pollicis girls like this year's give me
a lot so hey I was like why would I give
that to you it's a gift